as budding female footballers escaping
afghanistan was a matter of life or
death once the taliban took over
here a glimpse of the terrifying weight
at the border with pakistan by members
of the national girls junior team and
other players
faces hidden love of football kept a
secret too until they finally made it
over
now from a hotel in lahore two of the
footballers have agreed to speak for the
first time about their ordeal and their
hopes for sanctuary in the uk or
elsewhere
the taubons were very violent and they
always treated us
that
we don't know that who you are but if
you cannot pass the border we would kill
all of the all of you here that was the
last moment that we saw taliban and we
leave our
country country with pain
it was so hard for us it's not good for
me my family and my teams
yeah i can't imagine
i can't
live in afghanistan
[Music]
and afghanistan don't in my
country
this is sabrier in happier times when
her team won the national championship
last year
football a game she and her friends grew
up playing a passion they don't want to
lose we were playing football in a
backwarded country like afghanistan a
country that they
don't believe in women and they think
that women just
women just they have to stay at home but
on that situation on such a hard
situation we were playing football with
love
we really love football and it means
freedom for us
this group of 35 players and their
families have spent almost three weeks
in a hotel in pakistan waiting for a
country to offer them a home
but with just days left on their visas
time is running out and fear of being
forced back is growing
we would be really happy
that we can live in uk and have you here
as a host country for us the charitable
arm of a british based business that
helped the girls flee
hopes the uk will take aim at what it
sees as an open goal and let them in
we've been
really inundated with quite a few
football clubs premier league football
clubs and second
uh
firstly
other leagues that i've said
we would like to help
a happy ending for members of
afghanistan's female youth football
squad granted asylum in portugal their
fellow players back in pakistan though
yet to learn if they too will return to
the pitch the ibrahim sky news